opitz was genau interessiert und
fasziniert sie seit jahren am schicksal
von schrift losen völkern mich
fasziniert am schicksal das schicksal
nämlich dass viele dieser tradition
verschwinden ins in die stimme losigkeit
absenken werden bevor man sie
aufgezeichnet hat und mich fasziniert
das weil in diesem mündlichen
überlieferungen ein schatz verborgen
liegt der eine bedeutung hat die
sicherlich jener ähnelt die wir von den
großen ethischen traditionen in europa
kennen wie etwa die ilias oder die usa
wie ließe sich dieses geheimnis noch
etwas mehr umkreis noch etwas genauer
beschreiben
ja also vielleicht wenig konkreter also
ich beschäftige mich mit den mündlichen
überlieferungen der schrift losen völker
im himalaya solche traditionen gibt es
selbstverständlich auch in südamerika
oder in anderen teilen asiens aber ich
habe mich natürlich auf eine region
spezialisiert und dort die tradition die
mündlichen überlieferungen aufgezeichnet
in situ an ort und stelle und dann mich
mit hilfe einheimischer interpreten
daran gemacht diese dinge aufzuzeichnen
zu transkribieren und auch zu übersetzen
um dann am schluss gewissermaßen ein
korpus vorzufinden das in schriftlicher
form weitergegeben werden kann im für
künftige generation das heißt was wir da
machen wir ethnologen ist im grunde
genommen eine verwandlung einer
mündlichen in eine schriftliche
tradition
das würden wir nicht machen
wenn diese traditionen nicht verdammt
wären gewissermaßen durch die moderne
aus gehortet also da stehen die schrift
losen kleinen völker den großen
positionen eben aus unserer sicht den
höhergestellten tradition mit schrift
gegenüber
vielleicht eine wichtige präzisierung
auch schamanismus wenn wir dann von
dieser religiösen zeiten noch sprechen
das ist nicht etwas was nur mit den
indianern verbunden ist wie sich jetzt
richtig gesagt habe nebenbei den völkern
im himalaya formal haben sie das gefühl
ihren ja also das ist so
sie sind sozusagen von der mündlichen
gleich tradition gleich auf den
schamanismus gekommen das ist richtig
weil alle journalistischen traditionen
die es gab und noch lebt sind
traditionen der mündlichkeit es gibt
keine verschriftlicht humanistische
tradition wenn man abschied von kleinen
ecken in korea und in china und in der
mandschurei da gibt es auch schrift
verschriftlicht reform das schaffen
deswegen wird man sagen eine religion
wie kommen darf ohne schrift und ohne
dogma so ist es ja das ist ein ganz
zentraler punkt und dass diese tatsache
zieht gewissermaßen eine ganze serie
konzept von konsequenzen nach sich
erstens gesellschaften ohne schrift sind
fast immer gesellschaften ohne staat
sind gesellschaften außerhalb von
staaten natürlich wenn man sich genau
heute die situation an sieht es gibt
natürlich keine gesellschaften mehr die
sozusagen staaten frei auf weißen
flecken der erde war im raum ja eines
aber auch angebot und an den rand
gedrängten willig und all diese gebilde
diese kleinen lokalen traditionen die
auch lokale kleine
formen der religion praxis haben
unterscheiden sich eben von den großen
dadurch dass die religiösen aktivitäten
selbst nicht verschriftlicht sind nicht
gewissermaßen in ein katechismus in eine
kanonische form geprägt sind sondern
eben immer nur in mündlichkeit
weitergereicht werden
und da verschwindet mal was da kommt
wieder was neues dazu
und das allerwichtigste bei dem ganzen
ist es gibt keine exegese keine ausweg
eine auslegung und natürlich legen die
leute das aus und erzählen das was sie
gerade gesungen haben aber das
entscheidende ist der text und nicht die
interpretation wenn sie demgegenüber die
texte der schriftlichen religion sich
ansehen
da haben sie häufig ein urtext die bibel
den koran im buddhismus ist etwas anders
da gibt es viel mehr
und daneben unendlich viel akkumulierte
über die jahrhunderte akkumulierte
interpretation dieser einen schrift ja
das heißt wie sie haben immer ein
original und unendlich viele
interpretationen die ebenfalls
weitergereicht werden bei den mündlichen
überlieferungen und bei den
gesellschaften mit diesen kleinen
religionsformen wird nur weitergereicht
das was die originaltexte sind und diese
zum teil außerordentlich umfangreichen
da werden wir viel kennenlernen müssen
anliegen noch nachzutragen dass sie eben
selber in sich in ihrer persönlichkeit
sozusagen den feldforscher und den
ethnologen der an der universität lehrt
der in der forschung das ganze versuchte
einzuordnen vereinigen oder sie haben
lange zeit auch bei diesen völkern von
denen wir jetzt sprechen gelebt
sie haben wirklich feldforschung über
jahre in den 70er 80er jahren betrieben
und sind dann später
mit ungefähr 50 jahren hier in zürich
haben sich dem akademischen betrieb
ausgesetzt und sind professor geworden
jetzt vor kurzem hatten sie ihre
abschiedsvorlesung und da drin sagen sie
der ethno graf dort draußen ist ein
perlentaucher der kabarettist in der
heimischen werkstatt sein juwelier ich
finde es ein sehr schönes bild wenn sie
das für die perlenkette die dann
entsteht braucht es beides oder ja also
ob man da im wenn ich sage perlentaucher
dann heißt das natürlich letzten endes
auch sie wissen ja was perlentaucher
machen die 39 mal runter und kommen
nachher mit einer perle hoch ja so
ähnlich müssen sie sich auch die arbeit
des felt forschers vorstellen
ja da ist man hat nicht andauernd carlen
gewissermaßen die man hoch holt ja oder
die man sammelt an den orten wo man
seine feldforscher da gibt es sehr viel
frustrierenden alltag auch ja und sehr
viel entfremdung etwa wenn man lange
zeit an einem ort ist weil ja zum
beispiel bei diesen völkern wo ich
gelebt und gearbeitet habe ist nicht den
begriff der privatheit gibt es gibt
keine privatmann kann sich nicht
zurückziehen man ist der gesamtheit des
dorfes oder der gemeinschaft ohne
unterbrechung ausgelegt immer in
gesellschaft ja und das ist eine
erfahrung auf die wir in unserer welt
nicht eingerichtet sind und nicht etwas
darauf ja enorm der einsamkeit die bei
uns ja gilt nur wenn sie in der
eisenbahn fahren setzte sich ins abteil
und dann sind sie still
ja so n so still fast wie in der kirche
es kann mal zu einem gespräch kommen
oder sie ärgern sich über einen dazu
laut mit computer klappert oder handy
telefoniert aber ansonsten gilt die norm
der einsamkeit
das ist in solchen gesellschaften
absolut undenkbar also diese
gesellschaften ohne schrift
sind auch gesellschaften meistens die
viel reden
gehen wir mal konkret zu einem volk zum
volk der maya sie haben uns einige
bilder mitgebracht das ist im
nepalesischen himalaya gebiet ja schauen
wir uns mal so ein dorf an
auffällig wie dieses dorf in so einer
art terrassenlandschaft liegt ich nehme
an dass handgemacht das ist also ein
bagger dorf liegt etwa auf 2300 metern
hat unter sich sozusagen den fluss der
ist vielleicht 50 meter tiefer und dann
geht es über 4000 meter hoch den hang
und dahinter schließt sich an der
dhaulagiri 8000 so viel milder also
zweithöchsten berg der erde
und das ist wirklich eine mondlandschaft
aber so zusammen wie sie gesehen haben
auch terrassiert von menschenhand wie
groß ist diese folgerung gefährt das
volk hat etwa also die wenn man diese
marga mit dieser sprache nimmt es gibt
auch mal mit anderen sprache etwa 30.000
also es ist ein verhältnismäßig großes
kleines volk extrem abgelegen haben wir
eine gruppe von menschen um eine trommel
herum das sind hier sechs männer die
sitzen am rande des dorfes an einer
wegkreuzung wo sich geister verlaufen
können ja deswegen sitzen sie da und
sind zwei schamanen vier leyen das sind
gehilfen dieser schamanen und sie sind
im begriff eine trommel herzustellen
mit dem nächsten bild sind wir mitten in
einer harmonischen sitzung nämlich um
richtig also das sind zwei schamanen
einer ist in vollem ornat der andere
noch nicht das gespielt machte später
und das ist eine 2 nach cs die zwei
nächte und ein tag lang geht und ja und
das ist ein gravierendes ereignis da ist
jemand vom baum gefallen vom geist der
weißen
wieder hinab gestürzt worden und es gilt
nun hier auf dem bild sieht man dass
eine wan leiter herzustellen die dann
vor der tür des hauses aufgehängt wird
damit dieser geist nicht kommt das wird
aber erst gemacht am ende des jahres der
wird nämlich vorher herbei gelockt mit
einer eintönigen flöte in eine kalebasse
gezaubert diese wird zerschlagen und
außerhalb des dorfes weggeworfen
also da geht was auch im nächsten bild
ja ganz interessant ja auch dieses netz
wohl bedeutet also das ist ein ganz
normales fischernetz das sind die
angehörigen aus der gleichen serie aus
die wir von der wir eben sprachen das
sind die angehörigen des verunglückten
weil die auch gefährdet sind und die
werden während der gesamten sitzung
werden und eine protektive ein
schützendes fischernetz gepackt und
müssen so lange bleiben bis die gefahr
gebannt dass heißt der geist der weißen
kreide vertrieben wie lange kann das
dauern
40 stunden sowie im nächsten bild sind
schon bei einem tanz nämlich auf jahr
also am besten sieht man eine schamanin
ganz die zweite person ja das ist eine
gruppe von tanzenden schamanen im
verlauf einer initiation das heißt einer
instandsetzung in den stand des
schamanen eines neophyten eines neulings
welche rolle spielt das volk im nächsten
bild ja eine große rolle weil in dieser
gesellschaft und in vielen
gesellschaften dieser art sind alle
religiösen aktivitäten auch
heilungschancen die in einem hause
stattfinden öffentlich zugänglich wegen
weil es keine privatheit gibt jeder kann
jederzeit in jedes haus hinein laufen
und wenn eine journalistische aktivität
im gange ist in einer gesellschaft wo
die praxis noch lebendig ist
wie dort dann kommt jeder dahin weil das
ein großer unterhaltungswert da ist ja
und das ist wie ins kino gehen ja und
dann sind die leute dabei und dadurch
ergibt sich sozusagen eine absolute
gesellschaftlich kite jeder art von
religiöser praxis ja also wir haben
jetzt gesehen es gibt schon mal innen
und charmant es gibt frauen und männer
wer bestimmt du wirst schon in chamonix
niemand bestimmt dass man wird zum
schamanen und schamanen berufen von
einer übernatürlichen kraft in erster
linie von einem bereits verstorbenen
schamanen dessen reinkarnation man
werden könnte also man wählt nicht den
beruf sondern man kriegt sozusagen die
aufforderung ihn zu ergreifen und in der
aufforderung im mit der aufforderung
verknüpft sind eine ganze serie von
tests die einer durchlaufen muss ehe er
oder sie initiiert voll initiiert und
akzeptiert wird und akkreditiert wird
also so stellt sich damit derzeit erst
heraus ob das eine schamanin ingenieurs
eine echte berufung waren ja wann werden
die gerufen
die werden das kann jederzeit sein es
gibt welche die sind der jüngste dem ich
je begegnet war zwölf jahre alt und der
älteste dem ich bei der initiation
begegnet bin der war 52
er hatte sehr große mühe die sehr
strapaziösen prüfungen überhaupt
durchzustehen auch das wird sich über
tage hin strecken das geht über als die
ganze initiation phase die geht ein
halbes jahr und das dass das ihr
schließt nicht ein das lernen der
mündlichen überlieferung das dauert sehr
viel länger
das beginnt eigentlich erst nachdem man
wirklich initiiert ist akkreditiert ist
dann beginnt eine phase
des lernens der mündlichen überlieferung
der mythen der gesänge der epischen
gesänge und das dauert jahre
sieben acht bis zehn jahre jemand den
stoff im kopf hat also jetzt spüren wir
schon oder dass der begriff den wir von
schamanismus am damit ein event zu tun
haben kann mit dem was sie uns jetzt
berichten wir denken dann wenn wir ein
bisschen über feuer gehen und die kommen
ein bisschen angeschlagen dann hätten
wir schon ein journalistisches ritual
bei uns das ist was ganz andere stammen
wo unterscheidet sich dieser
schamanismus von diesen seien
oberflächlichen bildern ja also es geht
natürlich einerseits einen begriff der
sich eingebürgert hat
der begriff schamane oder schamanismus
der für alles mögliche herhalten darf
mehr begriffe sind ja geduldig und der
kann ja nichts dafür dass er für das und
jenes eingesetzt wird
ich selber habe eine engere definition
für humanismus wobei ich immer sofort
der zusage
es gibt ihn nicht im singular sondern es
gibt nur schamanismus richie lob haben
weil alle religionen die eine praxis
haben die man in diesem zusammenhang
sehen könnte jeweils lokale traditionen
sind und da sie lokale traditionen sind
die in sich örtlich gewissermaßen eine
gewisse ab gewisse abgeschlossenheit
haben ergibt sich daraus auch dass es
nur schamanismus leben kann ja und das
hat wiederum etwas damit zu tun dadurch
dass es keine kirche gibt die darüber
achtet oder darauf schaut dass es eine
vereinheitlichte überhaupt geben soll
die idee der vereinheitlichung ist in
diesen lokalen praktiken nicht gegeben
wenn überhaupt dann nur auf ganz
reduziert lokalem niveau
aber ich verstehe richtig dann geht es
praktisch für jede lebenssituation für
schicksalsschläge gibt es ganz klare
anweisungen
wenn die schamanin der schamane kommt
wie man damit umgeht in diesen völkern
die leute haben bestimmte erwartungen
meistens wissen die nicht genau was er
dann bei diesem oder jenen fall machen
wird und er weiß es auch nicht
er muss erst eine besondere das seien
ganz zentrale diagnose stellen weil die
die ursache sagen wir eines
unglücksfalles oder einer krankheit oder
auch eines todesfalles ja anders erklärt
wird als wir es tun
sie erklären dort die sache damit dass
es eine störung einer metaphysischen
balance die stattgefunden hat also
zwischen unserer welt und metaphysischen
auberginen ja einer jahre an einer reis
der welt oder geist welt das können gute
geister oder ambivalente geister sein
das können aber auch bösartige
hinterlistige geister sein das sind zb
leute die eines unnatürlichen todes
gestorben sind und nicht befriedete
ahnen werden die verwandeln sich in
solche bösartigen geister und versuchen
die lebenden auf ins unglück zu bringen
ja also da sind wir mittendrin ihr ein
weltbild das sieht natürlich ganz anders
darstellt wenn sie eben sagen dass diese
art von welt wiederhergestellt wieder
berichtigt werden muss oder dass wir das
verstehen genau und die diagnose besteht
darin dass der schamane als erstes
herausfinden muss was hat der eben das
unheil widerfahren ist den
übernatürlichen angetan wie ist er den
sozusagen auf die füße getreten und dann
wenn er weiß wer das war welchem geist
welcher über natur in diese person etwas
angetan hat dann muss er sich sagen so
jetzt versuchen wir einen ein geschäft
mit dem zu machen
er der geist der das verursacht hat hat
dem kranken oder dem verunglückten eine
seele gestohlen geraubt und der raub der
seele führt am ende zum tod der person
nun geht der schamane hin wenn er weiß
welcher geistes war und betet versucht
den den geist erstmal und das ist häufig
auch die sogenannte schamanen reise der
muss sich dahin begeben dann schlägt er
diesen bösen geist und diesem
ambivalenten geist ein geschäft vor das
darin besteht dass er sagt du hast jetzt
die seele gestohlen aber ich glaube wir
haben noch etwas viel besseres für dich
nämlich opfer blut gib uns die seele
zurück und du kriegst opfer ein blut
opfer und deswegen gehört zu jeder
journalistischen handlung oder zu jedem
ritual jedes immer auch ein flutopfer
dazu es gibt keine solche handlungen
ohne ein solches opfer weil nur das
opfer sozusagen den austausch also im
tausch vollendet und damit ein leitet
die wiederherstellung der balance ich
würde jetzt sagen für meine ohren klingt
das alles natürlich sehr fremd ich habe
mir gedacht jetzt wie sie erzählt haben
dass zb diese geschichten habe ich jetzt
an an biblische geschichten erinnert zb
neuen testament gibt so eine geschichte
wo jesus von nazareth geister aus treibt
die dann in eine große herde von
schweinen geht die sich dann die erde
stürzt sich dann ins meer also da gibt
es viele geschichten wo solche
besessenheit 'nen krankheit mit
besessenheit verbunden sind
aus all diesen heilungs geschichten zum
beispiel im neuen testament aber sie ja
auch in anderen tradition
aber wie gehen sie damit um dass das für
unsere ohren hier alles sehr fremd
klingt ja gut also fremd klingt etwas ja
in erster linie wenn man es nicht
begreift ja man kann meiner ansicht nach
alle religionen
sind alle religions- ansätze dieser
mündlichen überlieferungen auch
studieren und ihnen näher kommen um
sozusagen ein gesamtes dahinter steckt
ja immer ein gesamtes weltbild ja oder
wie die engländer sagen lot of ford ja
eine denkweise ja und die denkweisen
dieser völker um ist gesamtheitlich alle
dinge des lebens haben darin platz alles
was der mensch auch das beste was man
tut ist teil dieses weltbildes und das
verstehen heißt letzten endes an jedem
beliebigen punkt den man jetzt
betrachtend vor sich hat zu sehen
welches die verbindungen zu den
gesamtheitlichen welt bilden sind und
das ist ein prozess ein lernprozess ein
studierender ein prozess des studierens
des nachfragens dessen ordnance des
nordens des wieder weg dass wir wieder
wegwerfen neu anfangen svh ein endloser
prozess im grunde genommen
und was mich persönlich auch bewegt
bewogen hat dann das zu machen ist das
mit den informanten vor ort die
durchlaufen auch einen lernprozess in
ihrer eigenen kultur dadurch die hunters
zwar infos die könnten das erklären aber
sie erklären es sich nicht erklären erst
wenn sie gefragt werden ja also das ist
sozusagen ein dialektischer gemeinsamer
lernprozess an die gesamtheit eines
denkt systems heranzukommen
bei dem ist ihnen gar nicht darum geht
zu werten ist das eine mehr wert ist das
andere als überholt nein die ethnologie
ist ja letzten endes die kardinal
die wissenschaft des relativismus ja das
ist in der natur diese dieses geldes
angelegt ja man bewegt sich ja sozusagen
wenn man in eine andere kultur hinein
schritt bewegt man sich aus der eigenen
so langsam heraus
und je mehr man von der anderen erfährt
desto seltsamer kommt die natürlichkeit
die sogenannte natürlichkeit der eigenen
einem vor und das kann dazu führen sogar
dass man nachher der fremden kultur
näher steht als der eigenen ja dass man
beispielsweise an der eigenen kultur
leidet ja und dieser vorgang der ist
natürlich wenn man dann später wieder
zurück kommt ändert sich die perspektive
wieder und auch die gewichte verändern
sich aber eines wird bleiben man wird
nie mehr sagen können das ist richtig
das ist falsch
ein ethnologe der behauptet eine
weltanschauung sei wichtig oder gar nur
sein richtiger als eine andere
der hat noch gar nicht angefangen gehen
wir noch mal zurück zu den manga sie
haben ja schon ein paar bilder
mitgebracht die eine initiation einer
schamanin eines schamanen zeigen ja
genau das ist also ein musterbeispiel
hier es ist der höhepunkt einer
initiation der neophyt oder der der
initiierende muss während des rituals
einen baum besteigen der entlastet ist
und nur in der mitte irgendwo so eine
kleine plattform übrig lässt den muss er
besteigen und muss dann vier oder fünf
stunden mit verbundenen augen auf dieser
plattform hocken bleiben und darf nicht
unter fallen wenn er herunterfällt hat
er die gesamte prüfung nicht bestanden
währenddessen und das sieht man hier auf
dem bild greift nehmen die anderen
schamanen die ihn initiieren ihre
trommeln unter den arm
demonstrativ nicht spielend gehen in das
haus des initiieren zu initiieren und
halten dort ein riesiges bankett abwurf
sehr viel gegessen und noch mehr
getrunken wird der aber zu initiieren de
ist allein mit dem wind und muss sehen
dass er nicht runterfällt später kommen
die zurück und wenn er nicht
runtergefallen ist was sehr selten
passiert ich weiß von keinem fall hat er
die initiation bestand wird er die
standfestigkeit geprüft oder seine dass
diese erhöhte position heißt dass er das
wird geprüft ob er zwischen den welten
vermitteln kann
ob er sich zwischen der irdischen und
der übernatürlichen welt bewegen kann
und wenn er unter fällt kann es nicht so
ja das wird der auftrag zu einem opfer
seien ja das ist genauer gesagt ist das
auch im zusammenhang eines einer
initiation kurz bevor dieser initiieren
de den baum besteigt muss er aus der
menge der zuschauer die also eine dichte
mauer bildet herauslaufen besessen von
seinem bahn sein vorgänger im beruf
rennt durch die masse hindurch und muss
einen weißen wiederfinden
dann suchte und findet den sind wieder
auch der und demos besteigen er reitet
auf dem weder hält ihn an den hörnern
fest weiß team in die zunge und nimmt
ein bisschen blut mit währenddessen wird
er wieder geschlachtet der kopf wird von
einem meister genommen in den mund
genommen und dann klettert der den
baumhof um alle mahnen dieses blut opfer
zu geben dann wird der dann wieder kopf
wieder runter fallen werden wieder kopf
auf
wird ein zusätzlicher leber des
künftigen initianten dann nimmt der
initiant immer mit verbundenen augen den
widder kopf und das herz des getöteten
wie das in den mund und klettert auf den
baum das sind also sehr dramatische
momente in der sammlung sich alles
erklären lassen haben sie die sprache
dann gelernt ja also ich konnte vorher
paul ii und dann hatte ich die lokale
sprache gelernt und vor allen dingen das
wichtigste und weil sich auch am besten
noch beherrsche ist die ritual sprache
die es noch mal etwas anders
die also in der die gesänge von denen
wir vorhin schon andeutungsweise
sprachen bevor getragen werden das sind
kunstformen ein wichtiger moment wo wir
tun ja wahrscheinlich an toten ritual
das ist ja das ist ein bestattungsritual
für einen alten mann ein sehr
angesehenen alten mann dessen 85
ungefähr alt interessant ist dass hier
um ihn herum gruppieren sich sozusagen
die wichtigsten verwandtschaft gruppen
kind am kopf die söhne und an den seiten
auf der einen seite die einheiraten den
frauen in die linie dieses verstorbenen
und auf der anderen seite die männer
dieser frauen ja und damit sind
sozusagen die wichtigsten die
elementarsten allianz gruppen highlights
allianz gruppen versammelt an dieser
stelle
man könnte im grunde genommen wenn man
lustig wäre an an dem bild um den toten
herum sozusagen das gesamte
verwandtschaft system dieser
gesellschaft analysieren und darstellen
will ich jetzt nicht tun alles genau
geregelt wie lange dauert so eine
bestattung dann ja also achso und der
der tote wird auch geschminkt der wirt
verschont wenn er gestorben ist legt man
ihm eine münze in den mund wenn er so
wieder ausgebucht ist er nicht tot
das ein tolles test dann werden
weibliche gehänge werden auf ihn drauf
gelegt von den einheiten gruppen um zu
zeigen dass also auch die allianz
verwandten als trauernde und eben auch
als verwandte geld
das dauert für so zwei drei tage aber es
geht relativ schnell die bestattung gut
an hier werden die anderen dimensionen
sichtbar was passiert denn hier auf
diesem wege ja also da wenn ich ihnen
sage dass das auch mit dem toten ritual
zu tun haben werden sie mir das nicht
glauben weil da geht es ja und da sind
ein paar mädchen und jungen die sich
kaufen und das ist am ende eines toten
rituals
nachdem der tote begraben worden ist und
die periode der trauer
zum abschluss kommt wird ein
ausgelassenes fest veranstaltet im
verlauf dessen die jugendlichen die
nicht verheirateten jugendlichen ein
ringkampf veranstalten und sich
gegenseitig stinkendes ihr ins gesicht
schlagen das ist also ein großes gaudi
für die leute das ganze volk schreit vor
lachen aber die sich da sozusagen
ringens bekämpfen sind potenzielle
ehepartnerin und die idee dahinter ist
dass der tote aus seiner entfernten
sicht im jenseits sich noch einmal des
dorfes erfreut weiß das schön
das ist ein grab mit einer zerschlagenen
trommel
ja das ist also ein
das grab eines schamanen schamanen
werden anders bestattet als die laien
für sie wird eine auf häufung ist eine
art zylinder oder zucker wird ja eine
form gestaltet aus der rat dann ein
stück eines baumes das ist der so
genannte lebensbaum der gleiche die
gleiche art von warm wie auch für die
initiation verwendet wird das in der
lebensbaum und in seinen lebensbaum wird
wird eine federkrone hinein gehängt und
seine trommel die vorher deren membran
vorher zerschlagen wurde
das zerschlagen der trommel bedeutet
sein lied ist verstummt sie haben eine
trommel mitgebracht hier warum diese
trommel überlebt ja also wie sie sehen
ist die tram ist nicht zerschlagen ja
und das hat folgende bewandtnis mit auf
sich die meisten jerman haben nicht
einen sondern zwei drei oder mehrere und
wenn einer stirbt dann wird nur eine
zerschlagen und in den baum gehängt und
der hier diese trommel ist ein die
trommel eines vor über 100 jahren
verstorbenen mann
ich konnte das sozusagen das alter
ziemlich genau bestimmen weil der in den
anruf uns gesängen vorkommt und da
werden würden sie seit generationen und
generationen aufgeführt und wenn man
weiß wann die letzten leben kann man
sozusagen zurück reichte das also über
100 jahren die trommel ist auch über 100
jahre alt und man sieht auch daran sie
wird heute genauso hergestellt
die sie früher eher gewonnen also das
ist ein wildes wild ein wildtier in
coral man lässt mannschaft die ganzen
haare ab lässt am rand noch etwas stehen
und nimmt als rahmen die latte eines
baumes dem der initiant in einer vision
in einer traum vision gesehen hatten und
da gibt es also ein ganz langes ritual
über die herstellung dieses instrument
also verbindung von natur und kultur
genauso und die trommel ist eigentlich
sozusagen das buch der schamanen oder
das buch der schrift losen völker indem
man nämlich hier vollkommen richtig ja
die ganzen möglichen tradition abruft
oder was ist die funktion der trommel
genau
statt des buches wie in den schrift
gesellschaften haben die schrift losen
gesellschaften diese vom typ
schamanismus eine trommel mittels derer
sie sozusagen die gesänge sich ins
gedächtnis rufen indem sie auf die
trommel einschlagen ja und es gibt sogar
mythen in denen gesagt wird wir hatten
vorher mal ein buch wie er die schrift
dieses schrift lose volk wir hatten
einmal ein buch haben dann in einem
wettkampf mit einem buddhistischen lama
beispielsweise dem wettkampf verloren
der siegespreis war ein buch oder das
buch oder die bücher
der name hat es gewonnen und der
schamane stürzt also der wettkampf war
wer zuerst auf dem berg auf einem berg
kommt der sturz hinterrücks vom herunter
vom felsen und er ist auf den berg hoch
gegangen mit seiner trommel die fällt
runter bricht entzwei und das erklärt
weshalb in vielen gesellschaften nicht
am anton halbiert sind
sie sind haben nur eine mail ja weil
sozusagen die andere hälfte bei im
verlust des wettkampfes alle unsere gang
kaputt gegangen ist und statt des buches
hat er nun die trommel als die trommeln
ist sozusagen der buch ersatz wenn man
so will
das heißt es gibt die erzählungen das
schriftgröße völker auch einige staaten
ja und dann ins hintertreffen geraten
sind an den rand gedrängt wurden von
schrift tradition wie zum beispiel der
buddhismus ist ja in unserer meinung
einige sehr positive tradition der hat
aber in solchen ländern offenbar
kleinere völker auch an den rand
gedrängt ja auch das ist passiert
nicht nur der buddhismus natürlich noch
viele praktisch alle großen religionen
haben in der einen oder anderen weise
weil sie sich eben häufig auch mit
staaten verknüpft haben ja das ist ja
der entscheidende punkt dass mit mit der
macht des staates die kirchen oder die
religionen sich häufig freundlich
gestellt haben oder verbündet haben auch
natürlich gelegentlich angegriffen
wurden natürlich gab zwar immer ein
gerangel in allen diesen religionen aber
sie als größere gebilde haben auch
gewiss missionarische absichten verfolgt
der hinduismus ist vielleicht die
einzige von diesem und das ist also in
geringfügigen wasser nur sagen kann und
haben dann sozusagen diese kleinen
traditionen auch überrollt und überrannt
weil sie glaubten design das seien
falsche glaubensformen ja sie haben sie
ein bisschen einblick geben in das
weltbild dass sie mit dem schamanismus
mit den schriftlichen völkern verbindet
schauen wir noch auf das menschenbild
ich finde das interessant also zum
beispiel in der medizin oder wenn eine
person lang ist geheilt werden soll wird
auch nämlich haben eine schamanin ein
schamane gerufen
gehen sie selber jetzt zum arzt zum
beispiel oder die man jetzt mit ja oder
haben sie dann auch rituale
die ja also unsere rituale sind ja
ziemlich verkümmert ja wenn wir zum
natürlich haben wir sicher auch
bestimmte rituale was weiß ich dass man
sagt
bis zur schwelle des arztes sind es 726
schritte und wenn es mehr ist sterbe ich
wenn es weniger sind werde ich geheilt
also solche dinge
die kennen wir ja auch zur genüge bei
uns aber der vorgang ist natürlich ist
natürlich ein sehr weltlicher letzten
endes da wird eine diagnose gemacht und
dann werden wir maschinen eingestellt
und dann sagt man wissenschaftlich oder
naturwissenschaftlich das und das wirkt
auf die und die weisen die zahlen wobei
natürlich häufig die psychologische
dimension relativ außer acht gelassen
wird bei diesen religions- heilungs
formen spielt die psychologie eine
erheblich größere rolle
und deswegen kann man sagen weil diese
journalistischen praktiken handelt es
sich letzten endes um glaubens heilungen
ja die h sind immer mit einer glaubens
form verknüpft was nicht heißt dass wir
ja auch hin und wieder glauben dass wir
sagen ich vertraue dem arzt mehr als
jenen oder das lamm ärzten schon
zurückgehe allein auf der schwelle
ich glaube mit avantgarde als die erste
das erste das herz transplantiert hat
der ist gut ja also wäre es ist er tot
so in dieser art also wir haben ja wir
bringen ja auch immer jede menge
glaubens
elemente in die heilung mit aber eben
bei uns muss eigentlich blick auf dem
körper das individuum geheilt werden
jetzt heilung im harmonischen kontext
welches menschenbild steht denn da in
das muster geheilt werden bei der natur
haben sie ja unser erklärt dass es darum
geht eben diese größe und zusammenhänge
wieder in ordnung zu bringen genau das
ist bei einer krankheit ja da ist genau
der selbe weil eine krankheit auch eine
ist gewissermaßen ein vergehen ist
vonseiten dessen bekannt geworden ist an
der über natur und die über natur ist in
der natur sozusagen ja und gleichzeitig
ist er aber nicht allein betroffen
sondern alle mitglieder seiner familie
oder seines clans oder seiner gruppe
lokalen gruppe und deswegen besteht auch
ein großes interesse jenseits der person
der familienmitglieder sogar des ganzen
dorfes dass diese person wieder in die
normalen bahnen hinein
zurückgeführt wird ja dafür brauche ich
eine schamanin einen schamanen ja dazu
braucht man einen termin oder schamanen
obwohl natürlich man muss sagen diese
gesellschaften leben ja nicht mehr in
der weise isoliert wie das vielleicht
früher gewesen ist oder nur in kenntnis
anderer ähnlicher gesellschaften sondern
eben am rande von modernen
gesellschaften und deswegen wissen die
natürlich auch dass es krankenhäuser
gibt und mitunter gehen die dann auch
dorthin ja wenn sie es bezahlen können
dahin zu kommen und dann auch noch den
krankenhausaufenthalt oder was weiß ich
zu bezahlen dann machen die das oder
machen es gelegentlich ja und die
schamanen selbst sehen das nicht als
konkurrenz weil es ein anderes system
ist ja wer das denn wenn wir jetzt die
medizin mal weglassen gap den parallelen
zur analyse zum beispiel und ja
gibt es das ist mitunter schon mal
behandelt worden so zum beispiel auch in
einem sehr interessanten aufsatz von
claude lévi-strauss ehrenloge wo er
einen fall untersucht hat wie eine
schwangere frau die eine schwierige
geburt behandelt wird und für diese
person wird ein mythos ein kollektiver
mythos vom schamanen vorgetragen
die frau muss versuchen sozusagen die
hauptpersonen des mythos sozusagen sie
selbst in diese rolle hinein zu sehen
gerade in einem natur folgen ja ja ja ja
und dann also ich muß sich sozusagen
identifizieren mit der protagonistin des
mythos und diese person hat dasselbe wie
sie sie hat also eine schwere geburt
und dann aber kommt das interessante im
mythos stirbt die person
bevor das aber ist muss sich sozusagen
die kranke frau die schwanger person die
leidet muss sich sozusagen abkapseln und
absetzen von der mythischen figur und
dann kann sie sagen sie stirbt im mythos
wort gestorben und im leben wird weiter
gelebt und das ist in sich selbst ein
langes eine lange prozedur an der die
ganze öffentlichkeit das ganze dorf oder
jedenfalls wer kommen möchte daran
teilnimmt und ein ein vorgehen wo
gewissermaßen ein kollektiver mythos
individuell angenommen wird während in
der psychoanalyse ein individueller
mythos nämlich die geschichte die der
patient seinem analytiker erzählt
geschaffen wird und sich dann abfinden
muss mit dem eigenen mythos oder
erkennen muss dass es ein solcher ist ja
also es gibt da ähnlichkeiten und
natürlich auch verschiebung und
unterschiede
haben sie jetzt um normal zu fahren in
ihrem alltag wenn sie sich so lange
damit beschäftigt haben rituale aus
anderen tradition sie meinen ob ich sehe
ja mal übernommen habe nicht als ich
wusste das glaube ich
oder anders gefragt wie hat sie die
beschäftigung mit dieser kultur mit dem
schamanismus verändert ja gut das ist ja
ziemlich naheliegend ich meine wenn sie
jetzt was weiß ich
wenn sie die arme schoss übersetzen ja
auch wenn er wenn die personen die da
vorkommen in einer kultur angehören die
zwei- oder dreihunderttausend jahr
zurückliegt dann werden sie da auch in
der gewissen weise einsteigen
so geschieht es selbstverständlich auch
wenn man sich mit einer mündlichen
tradition auseinandersetzt und noch
selbstverständlich umso mehr als man ja
auch noch in diese gesellschaft reisen
kann sie ist ja gleichzeitig ja sie
simultan sie ist jetzt dick und wenn sie
dort also längere zeit auch noch
verbracht haben und gelebt haben es
ergibt sich von alleine
dass sie dann gewisse ja wie soll man
das ja distanzen zur hiesigen welt
bekommen haben und die kleinen
weisheiten die es in diesen
gesellschaften gibt vielleicht auch ein
bisschen intern analysieren und sich
übernehmen ja ich hab mir doch die hat
ein zitat von ihnen gefunden in einem
gespräch letzten in einer zeitung muss
ich sagen du es dir das fremde in dem
maße an in dem dir das eigene fremd wird
es gibt auch manche die an diesem
prozess zu erstellen
ja das wäre so ein element das wir gegen
mit dem fremden dass wir so ein element
das ist sagen wir mal einen die
grundkonstellation
jedes ethnologen der sich sozusagen in
seiner tätigkeit seiner tätigkeit
voraussetzt das heißt der auch
feldforschung hat zerschellt sind sie
offensichtlich nicht kann ich kaum weiß
ich nicht vielleicht nicht mehr als alle
anderen
keine ahnung wenn wir die app locker wie
die ethnologie noch ins gespräch bringen
mit der philosophie ja was würden sie
denn sagen wo sind da die unterschiede
ja gut also dann müsste man vielleicht
so ein bisschen ausholen und in die
geschichte zurück gehen etwa 30-40 jahre
zurück es gab wo etwa 30 40 jahren mal
eine krise der philosophie und der lag
daran dass in einer gewissen weise die
europäische philosophie nicht mehr sich
in der lage sein oder auch nicht mehr
bereit war sozusagen die königs
wissenschaft zu repräsentieren und da
gab es aus den kreisen der philosophen
interessanterweise leute die behaupteten
wie zb jacob taubes oder wier et die
sagten wir wollen das auch nicht aber
wir hätten eine wissenschaft die unseren
alten platz einnehmen könnte und das ist
die ethnologie
nun haben die ethnologen sich ein solch
hohen sitzplatz hochsitz gewissermaßen
niemals erträumt und wandern auf diese
inthronisierung möglichkeit nicht
richtig reagiert oder auch abweisend
reagiert aber man muss schon sagen
allein die tatsache dass die ethnologie
alert die eigene perspektive
mit in den blick der erkenntnis zu
nehmen und den wechsel der eigenen
perspektive mit zu bedenken dass daraus
vielleicht auch andere arten von
erkenntnissen bestehen na das ist ja ein
alltäglicher vorgang letzten endes für
den ethnologen ist philosophisch gesehen
hoch interessant ja weil es ein
hermeneutische gesichtspunkt und eine
psychologische gesichtspunkt in sich
trägt dh der ethnologe praktiziert eine
haltung die eben sehr fraglich ist oder
fragwürdig ist und sich selbstständig
immer wieder fragen muss was ist jetzt
hier meine klick richtung was ist meine
position und das zeigt sich natürlich
auch in der tatsache der sich ändernden
praktiken in der ethnologie der moden
auch die stattgefunden haben und der
felder mit denen man sich in der
ethnologie beschäftigt hat sie haben
jetzt einige fragen aufgeworfen die eben
in der philosophie form des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts eine große rolle gespielt
haben
sie haben in ihrer antrittsvorlesung ja
aber vorher aus der abschiedsvorlesung
etwas vorgelesen in ihrer genau jetzt
standort genau gleich aus der publica ja
ja das wollte es auch ne idee da haben
sie gesagt dass es ihnen darum geht also
wie sie angefangen haben als professor
die reale probleme die realen probleme
wirklicher menschen zu behandeln
das heißt das schien ihnen eben in frage
gestellt dass man in der technologie
über die wirklichen probleme der
menschen spricht ja aber das ist da ist
es der auftrag das ist der alte auftrag
von max elmos ja der gesagt hat einer
unserer alten ahnen gewissermaßen einer
unserer forscher mahnen wenn man so will
der hat gesagt was zählt in der
ethnologie ist der und der melanesier
von der und der in
und das unterschreibe ich vollkommen und
das ist nun auch ein punkt der natürlich
für die ethnologie von großem interesse
ist nämlich sozusagen diesen bewegungen
die sie vollzieht sie ist die
wissenschaft des konkreten es geht immer
um ganz spezifische dinge
dieses dorf den und den der so und so
heißt in dem und dem dorf und seine
position innerhalb dieser lokalen
gesellschaft das ist das heranzoomen
sozusagen eine tätigkeit jeder
feldforschung betreiben muss dann aber
muss er sozusagen die kamera wieder
zurückziehen und eine weitere eine
distanzierte perspektive einnehmen und
dieses wechselspiel der distanzen ja nah
und fern konkret und abstrakt konkret
und verallgemeinernd das sind vorgänge
das sind gedanken bewegungen die der
ethnologe vollzieht als natürlich
vollzieht weil sie gewissermaßen in
seiner tätigkeit angelegt sind und das
ist auch letzten endes abgesehen davon
dass die ethnologie auch holistisch ist
sie beschäftigt sich mit allem was der
fall ist
in realen gesellschaften ist die
ethnologie auch in von daher gesehen
eine transdisziplinäre wissenschaft und
vielleicht aufgrund dieser tatsache
verdient sie auch zumindest einen
ähnlichen posten oder positionen zu
haben wie die philosophie jetzt ist es
ganz deutlich geworden
und das gibt's ja die hand mit dem was
sie am anfang erläutert haben eben mit
den perlen die getaucht werden und dann
zu einer kette aussortiert aufgereiht
werden
was werden sie jetzt machen sie sind
immer regiert wo geht ihr augenmerk hin
was werden sie in zukunft beobachten in
zukunft also die in der nächsten zukunft
die allernächste zukunft ist eine
ausstellung die
ich mit jungen wissenschaftlern hier von
der universität zürich mache über die
naga ein volk hinter indien die lange
zeit isoliert waren die aber drei
gewaltige wellen der unterdrückung und
geradezu kulturellen vernichtung hinter
sich gebracht haben die erste die
englische kolonialzeit die zweite die
christianisierung praktisch 100 prozent
die christianisierung und die dritte der
indische staat und was sozusagen an
alten noch übrig bleibt und was an neuem
entstehen muss durch diese art von
neuzeitlichen globalen teilweise
konfrontationen das sind
selbstverständlich auch dinge mit denen
sich die denen sich die ethnologie zu
sehen
gegenüber sieht weil die welt sich
verändern michael opitz alles gute für
die nächsten schritte und herzlichen
dank für dieses gespräch
schönen dank
[Musik]